let's go uh next where are we going next
by the way let's go to george from the
uk george welcome
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
hey yeah so um long time listener second
time caller um so as you probably
remember boris johnson was um removed a
few weeks ago indeed the conservatives
after months and months of political
pressure yep um and a kind of turning
point was reached and a max mass exodus
that kind of occurred and mass
resignations and the government could
essentially no longer function
um
the actual scandal that broke the
camel's back
wasn't the worst boris johnson scandal
but it was kind of the cherry on the top
after you know months and months of just
awful behavior um
and a kind of additional data point here
before i get to my question is that the
conservatives have seen as very ruthless
and removing political leaders um i
don't know if you're aware of that but
it's kind of a reputation that they have
yes
um and it got me thinking about trump
and how things in politics can move so
quickly
um things are kind of looking more and
more shaky for trump than ever as you've
covered fox news is laying the
groundwork to potentially support
another nominee
um and the republican establishment as
well is maybe looking for other you know
leaders
so i was wondering if if something
happens like a charge from the doj or
something else like that do you think
something analogous could happen to
trump as it did with johnson so you know
the establishment suddenly turns and
goes all in on desantis or someone like
that
will the you know will the republican
face
follow the establishment and
you know yeah and go all in or is this
situat situation just so different
and you know trump's personality cult of
personality is so strong
that they you know the establishment and
or the base could never abandon him i
don't think we know the answer to that
yet i i don't i think it's going to be
it's not going to be one or the other so
let's let's just pick a number let's
imagine that trump's real base is
30 million people okay just to pick
something so that means that
that
of his votes what did he get 70 million
votes 60 something i forget the numbers
let's say he got 70 million votes in
2020. 30 million
are probably all but guaranteed
and then the other 40 million votes that
trump got are some combination of
reluctant republican supporters of trump
who just really don't like democrats
people who like trump's tax policy but
dislike other stuff
confused people you know i don't know
right so you start to kind of slice it
up and then you have to say okay so like
if the rnc says trump's out desantis is
in
what does that do to these different
groups well he probably keeps most of
the 30 million trump does
but then how much of the 40 million does
he keep and then it's just really kind
of a math question and we just don't
know where that equation's gonna land
yeah i think so as well and i think it
also depends if if trump is eventually
kind of pushed out by the establishment
and it comes to a general election in
24. do those 30 million do they all
go okay well you know trump isn't on the
ticket so i might as well vote for
desantis right or do some become
disengaged again as they were pre-2016 i
think it's a combination i think there
are people who when trump is no longer a
shiny object that's interesting to them
on a ballot
they they uh exit politics back to
where where they came
and i just don't know how many i mean
we're talking about 30 million it's an
imaginary number i don't know how many
of the 30 million that applies to
yeah i guess we'll we'll just wait and
see
we will
all right uh george thank you for the
call i appreciate it
thanks david all right we're going to
take the quickest of breaks
but we're going right back to the phones
so there are still plenty more
opportunities to chat with me just hold
on if you're holding and we will be
right back